[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di voi hanno mai pensato di
mettersi in gioco di candidarsi per fare
i politici per chi di voi ha risposto sì
non preoccupatevi con me il vostro
segreto è al sicuro ma che lo abbiate
pensato oppure no sicuramente ci sono
dei fattori che dovreste prendere in
considerazione tanto per cominciare la
nostra è una democrazia cioè una forma
di governo basata sulle intuizioni
straordinaria per cui dovrebbe essere il
cittadino al centro del processo
decisionale
questo significa che dovrete convincere
il cittadino a votare per voi ma noi
elettori sappiamo bene che molto spesso
non riusciamo ad arrivare all'occasione
di voto davvero preparati e informati
specialmente su temi molto complessi e
finiamo per votare per l'intuizione per
istinto per simpatia per antipatia o per
tradizione storia familiare
d'altra parte i vostri avversari
politici potranno dire ciò che vorranno
e sarà molto difficile per l'elettore
distinguere tra quelle promesse
irrealizzabili efficaci e le fantasie
per non parlare poi del l'importo
economico di cui avrete bisogno per
farvi conoscere le vostre lettori che
finirà per costargli qualche favore un
po ingombrante
insomma per queste altre ragioni la
democrazia sta conoscendo una crisi che
ci porta portano ai lettori a percepire
il politico come un élite un po lontana
dai nostri interessi che protegge
qualcun altro anche se questi temi in
realtà non sono nuovi se pensiamo che lo
stesso churchill diceva che la
democrazia la peggiore forma di governo
esistente ad eccezione di tutte quelle
provate fino ad oggi
allora proviamo a fare un esercizio
diverso è se fossimo noi a disegnare il
nostro governo ideale che
caratteristiche avrebbe beh non so voi
ma il mio sarebbe almeno nazionale cioè
perseguirebbe come unico obiettivo
l'ottimo il benessere per tutta la
comune
sarebbe anche competente sulla materia
sulla quale è chiamato a decidere
sarebbe consapevole di ciò che è
accaduto nel passato
cosa ha funzionato e cosa no ma sarebbe
anche visionario saprebbe trovare
soluzioni nuove
sarebbe sicuramente lungimirante
dovrebbe prevedere le conseguenze delle
proprie azioni del breve medio e lungo
termine e sarebbe trasparente
incorruttibile
ciò sarebbe possibile per noi cittadini
sapere perché ha preso quella decisione
sulla base di quali dati vi ricorda
qualcuno
no vero neanche a me però mi ricorda
qualcosa
c'è una tecnologia anche recentemente
sta conoscendo grande popolarità pur
essendo ben più antica che ha dimostrato
di avere caratteristiche più o meno
simili
e sto parlando dell'intelligenza
artificiale tanto per cominciare
l'intelligenza artificiale a razionale
perché matematica gli algoritmi di
intelligenza artificiale e apprendono
sulla base di un procedimento detto
allenamento che li porta a determinare
quei parametri essenziali che permettono
loro di raggiungere l'ottimo che cos'è
questo ottimo l'ottimo per un algoritmo
che deve identificare gli oggetti in
un'immagine non è nient'altro che il
numero minimo di errori compiuti o il
regime minimo di tassazione da applicare
ai cittadini pur mantenendo i servizi
fondamentali dello stato la scuola
l'istruzione e così via
l'intelligenza artificiale molto
competente
se pensiamo a quella branca al machine
learning fatta di algoritmi che studiano
i dati studi al passato alcuni studiano
intere librerie milioni e milioni di
documenti per sostenere dibattiti quadri
realistici dunque conosce il passato
studio al passato ma è anche creativa
innovativa verso il futuro
basti pensare a quegli algoritmi
generativi che generano immagini
artificiali in testi artificiali fino
addirittura opere d'arte in pittura ma
anche in prosa o in poesia
e che dire poi di quelli algoritmi
predittivi che studiano le connessioni
del presente e correlazioni che il
nostro occhio non vede e cercano di
prevedere il futuro e lo fanno molto
bene con i nostri click con il decorso
di una malattia o con la prossima mostra
del nostro avversario solo
incorruttibilità e sulla trasparenza
so già cosa direte impossibile che i
modelli come questi siano comprensibili
e del resto è vero ha dato corrotto
sbagliato falsificato corrisponde un
risultato danneggiato pregiudizievole ed
è vero esistono degli algoritmi modelli
talmente complessi che apprendono
autonomamente i loro parametri che non
sono sempre così facili da scomporre in
realtà questo è un problema noto
nell'intelligenza artificiale e tecniche
nuovi studi nuovi ogni giorno cercano di
trovare nuove soluzioni a queste sfide
ed è per questo che è necessario ed è
fondamentale che questi modelli questi
algoritmi restino aperti e disponibili
per tutta la comunità insomma assumiamo
che esista soltanto per un attimo
assumiamo che esista un deciso la
nazionale competente consapevole del
passato ma innovativo creativo
lungimirante trasparente incorruttibile
normale ma se esistesse un decisore come
questo avrebbe ancora senso chiedere ai
cittadini di decidere in materia di
energia nucleare in materia di
permanenza o abbandono dell'unione
europea cioè avrebbe ancora senso
chiedere a noi cittadini di decidere per
il bene della comunità beh forse no
forse se esistesse un agente come questo
un decisore come questo e proprio a
questo decisore che dovrebbe essere
chiesto di prendere quelle decisioni più
complesse che comprendono tanti fattori
forse se esistesse un decisore come
questo non ci sarebbe più dibattito sul
cambiamento climatico e le guerre sti
combatterebbero per simulazione possiamo
addirittura immaginare
sistemi di intelligenze cosiddetti
agenti autonomi capaci di rappresentare
punti di vista differenti prospettive
differenti obiettivi differenti e
chiedere a loro di aiutarci a negoziare
dialogare ottenere il compromesso
migliore
pensiamo ancora all'unione europea la
decisione di abbandonare o meno l'unione
europea non è poi una negoziazione tra
la gente la prospettiva sistema
sanitario e quella sicurezza e quella di
politica interna e di politica estera
dunque è finita così abbiamo trovato i
nostri decisori ideali non c'è più posto
per noi uomini e donne reali no non è
proprio così
quello che dovrebbe tornare al cuore di
un dibattito radicalmente democratico
dovrebbe essere la determinazione di
quei valori che ci caratterizza come
essere umani si tratta cioè di
utilizzare quella che per aria la nostra
capacità di comunicare e di collaborare
tra noi quello che facciamo meglio di
qualsiasi altra creatura vivente per
metterci d'accordo su quei vincoli su
quel perimetro all'interno del quale il
decisore dovrebbe andare ad operare
cioè si tratta ad esempio di chiedersi
ma un veicolo autonomo che si trova in
condizioni di frenata di emergenza e
deve sacrificare uno fra due passanti
dovrebbe scegliere il giovane all
anziano il malato o e sano l'uomo o la
donna il buono o il cattivo o non
scegliere proprio
e che dire di quelle decisioni in
materia di personale di salute personale
dove finisce la mia libertà e dove
inizia la tua
in realtà questo concetto di ottimo
globale non è poi così diversa da quello
che nell'antica grecia nella culla della
democrazia veniva chiamato l'utile già
protagora ci diceva che stiamo individua
la sua verità non tutte le verità sono
ugualmente utili alla vita associata una
sul piano pratico e migliore
perché la più idonea alla realizzazione
di una più larga e profonda armonia fra
i cittadini
questo non è un conto di maggioranza
questo dialogo non compromesso una sorta
di contratto sociale alla hobbs orso
utopia in una società globale come la
nostra raggiungere un unico punto di
vista beh noi abbiamo già fatto qualcosa
di simile qualche anno fa quando abbiamo
stabilito che ci sono alcune metri che
matematicamente rigorose fondamentali
che determinano la condizione di
benessere di un paese per esempio il pil
e allora forse in una nuova bretton
woods potremmo decidere nuovi valori che
percepiamo possano rappresentare
correttamente il nostro benessere la
sostenibilità delle nostre vite
personali e professionali
e se è troppo difficile rappresentare un
unico punto di vista in una società come
la nostra perché non ricorrere ad
esempio ad uno schema ad agenti dove
agenti differenti rappresentino visioni
differenti prospettive differenti e ci
aiutino ancora una volta a raggiungere
il compromesso migliore il decisore che
vi ho descritto non esiste erano
elementi di asimov di leibniz e di tanti
altri ma oggi le intelligenze sono
superumane sua attività molto specifiche
molto specializzate quello che ci manca
è sostanzialmente un linguaggio comune
che permetta a noi di codificare
all'interno delle macchine la
complessità della nostra realtà e ci
permetta di spiegare quanto fenomeni
globalmente complessi nello spazio e nel
tempo sia nella realtà profondamente
legati tra loro ma noi dobbiamo iniziare
oggi
innanzitutto dobbiamo iniziare ad
accettare che questa tecnologia da
comprendere non da temere e non soltanto
chi come me né scrivere il codice di
funzionamento tutti i giorni non
soltanto chi siede in cattedra ma tutti
noi dobbiamo capirne i rischi sporcarci
le mani per capirne le potenzialità le
opportunità e gli approcci
dobbiamo spostare il dibattito politico
democratico su quei valori che ci
caratterizzano come esseri umani
dobbiamo determinare noi i valori che ci
caratterizzano e dobbiamo ad esempio
stabilire ma dove finisce la privacy e
dove inizia la sicurezza nazionale
dove finisce la libertà di parola e dove
inizia l'inganno perché quando le
intelligenze artificiali saranno
abbastanza potenti da fornirci le
risposte noi dovremmo sta per porre le
domande quelle giuste per evitare che ci
rispondano qualcosa tipo 42 e quando
saranno abbastanza potenti da fornirci
la soluzione migliore e dovremo sta per
dire che cosa significa migliore perché
altrimenti lo farà qualcun altro
qualcos'altro al nostro posto
questa è la nostra partita decidiamo noi
le regole
grazie
[Applauso]